don't [ __ ] have it I will deliver
your rings all that Babel it's such
Capaldi here I'm gonna be watching some
of your clips and try guess what happens
dicks so this is a man who definitely
looks like he's maybe a hungover or
camping here that here the options a a
lightning straight causes the boy to
scream be the tent is blown away by the
wind see a startled deer on the street
for the tent and when I say a lightning
strike causes them to scream cuz it
looks like a [ __ ] [ __ ]
I was right okay so options are a the
cat gives the ghetto the finger poorly
what did CAD start smacking his sister
head hats her sister to stop him stop or
singing she's been singing for quite
some time he's pissed off so I'm packing
C but I'm having a sister we shall see
with a pool so he's doubts telling him
to dribble with football and here we go
after the cat volleyball into his dad's
testicles and an absolute classic the
kid floors a tantrum on schemes I hate
football
I'd be play ball and [ __ ] I hope
that's not me [ __ ] a shape video and
the CAD mess understands what it means
to trouble with the ball I mean I want
them it to tick you take ok his dad's
balls because the other two seem like
why would you even send us an F it's
either of those other two things and
when we [ __ ] region voice betting on
the ball see it's quite cute that's not
how you travel you're right well I
understand though it was a cute video I
thought we were doing funny things so
here we go there's another child so I'm
gonna assume it's um I want cute video
rather than one that I'm actually going
to enjoy
Hey you ready you know who's gonna hide
okay go on then
ready I'm gonna count then go one two
and as it seems like it's gonna be
another cute one so can't wait to not
give a [ __ ] about this
where has the ghetto had an I got a and
the Fred be under the dog see no no
there Bobby
I think she's maybe had to hope she's
not had in the friends I'd be a [ __ ]
night now I want to go for B under the
dog ten coming in ready at all [ __ ] she
stuffed up so much going on here
comatose ever a check on her look I says
let's make sure our well-being is okay
before will I share with us yet she said
I'm a [ __ ] lifeless on the [ __ ]
[ __ ] hell oh that's it this is
already interesting me that's one for
some reason please the strange strange
bunch have an oval other waiting
I mean I'd imagine I think that I was
going to try to bring them the rings
maybe and just get like yeah yeah yellow
cousin to do or something the options we
call here are a there will attacks the
best man be the arrow flies headfirst
into the window and not to self oh I'll
see that I will does a poo on a breath
of disappear on the braid I think maybe
the arrow flies headfirst until when
they were not to sell folks to us so
that's B which is here so with any luck
the sewol is going to absolutely fly
will fly
is that the bad bat fly [ __ ] is off the
tear surely I shouldn't have to say this
but don't [ __ ] have a devil to other
your rings someone holding a highlighter
so I'm already [ __ ] stunning with
what this could be a the highlighter
exclusion has his head oh don't worry
flora someone well
you've spoiled that as a guy attempts to
the catch has cheer closes collapses
well he makes no look I mean makes a no
look catch that was some terrible
reading on my pop-up in developing never
go for one of those senses like the idea
of a making a no-look catch and that's
not being one of embarrassment let's
celebrate this man Jamie catcher lend
all that can't you didn't I mean I don't
wait yeah I'd be a pedantic yeah but and
all that calves would be uncle s what
that is is it as a happy coincidence so
it's an absolute he's an absolute forty
so Jamie if you'd open yeah [ __ ] you
[Music]